why is it so hard to find someone to
help me
why does everyone just
not even believe this is real i i
i can't even imagine
honestly my god
i do not know how this is gonna end
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're picking up on my sibo
journey with a little update on where
i'm currently at but first let me tell
you about my sponsor betterhelp so as
you guys know i have struggled with
anxiety my whole life and getting my
mental health under control is actually
a really important part of my gut
healing journey since the brain and gut
are so intimately connected so i
recently discovered betterhelp which is
the world's largest online therapist
network with over 20 000 licensed
professional therapists it's not a
crisis line or a self-help line it's
professional therapy done securely
anywhere anytime online so basically you
can log into your account anytime to
send a message to your therapist and get
a timely response so you don't need to
wait weeks between appointments when
maybe you're dealing with something very
pressing or time sensitive it's also a
lot more affordable than traditional
in-person therapy and there's also
financial aid available to those in need
so if you're struggling with your mental
health check out betterhelp.com
abby's kitchen to get 10 off of your
first month of therapy that's better
h-e-l-p and you can join over 1 million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional all right back to my video
now before we get too into it please
pause the screen to check out my
disclaimer including a reminder that my
sibo protocol is mine and mine alone
please do not try to attempt this always
speak to a registered dietitian or a
health care provider about your unique
needs now in case you guys don't know a
quick little recap back at the beginning
of 2021 i was diagnosed with sibo and
sibo stands for small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth now there are a lot
of potential causes of sibo um most
people tend to get it from a really bad
bout of food poisoning but in my case
it's theorized that i actually got it
from doing four rounds of antibiotics
from having back to back cases of
mastitis five times not three
not four
when i was pumping for baby e now i
tried to treat it earlier this year and
while i felt amazing during treatment
unfortunately my treatment and
medication options were limited because
i was breastfeeding so it just was not
strong enough to eradicate it for good
now that i've weaned the [ __ ] is back
[Music]
and i'm gonna kill that mother
bacteria so let me take you along on my
journey yes love that journey for me
first we need a baseline and that means
doing the god awful sibo breath test
again if you remember from my last video
this means two whole days of eating
nothing but chicken eggs white rice
white bread oil and clear broth no fiber
no spices no coffee
my life
kill me so to prepare i did some meal
prepping and i made some big batches of
chicken and big batches of rice and
broth so for two days i had toast with
eggs for breakfast i had chicken and
rice in broth with some bread for lunch
and then i had some rice with chicken
and bread for dinner creative i know but
i was just desperate to get through that
damn test
and so we meet again well
let's do this
that does not feel like it's working
[Applause]
i hope i did that right
one eternity later
that's so good that tastes like
so good today ugh i also just wolf down
an entire container of cantaloupe so
that went down um and i am having a
peach and some yogurt and some mini
muffins and some crackers as a pre-lunch
snack because i kind of skipped
breakfast so yeah just warming up for
lunch and it's gonna be a good day gonna
be a good day today
that's not a real song
all right let me drink my coffee one
week later okay so i just got an email
with the results from my sibo test and
not surprisingly based on my symptoms
it's still positive
um and it's still positive for the
methanogenic bacteria which is what i
had predominantly last time though just
based on symptomology there's also a
little bit of suspicion that i also have
some hydrogen bacteria as well and
actually this time it's even a little
bit worse which apparently is not
uncommon with stubborn methanogenic
bacteria it can be really hard to treat
and fully eradicate
so the plan here is that i'm going to
start a new biofilm disruptor this is
what they call like a phase 2 biofilm
disruptor because it's a little bit more
aggressive than the nac that i took with
my first two rounds of antibiotics so
i'm taking something called bismuth
style complex bismuth i don't know how
is that bismuth by all clump
the
bismuth my name is sammy they call me
sammy franklin style complex i feel like
i have to have a lisp in order to say
that um and i have to take it for two
months
which sucks because i really just want
this whole phase to be over with and to
be on the other side of feeling great
and recovered but here we are and now
that i have come to the end of my
breastfeeding journey i can finally
start to take that so i guess we're
gonna have to see how this goes
so i am
very very frustrated this week i'm
having a hard time getting the
you know appropriate protocol prescribed
to me like to actually get the
medication so basically in short the
challenge is that rifaximin is the kind
of go-to
evidence-based antibiotic for treating
sibo you would basically you know
everyone takes rifaximin if they're
going to do the antibiotic root and i
took that two doses of it but the
evidence suggests that we actually want
to pair it with another antibiotic to
really eradicate the sibo and the type
of sibo that i have methanogenic
dominant um best practice for that is to
pair the rifaximin with something called
neomycin which is another antibiotic now
here in canada neomycin has what we call
like a black box warning so that means
that it comes with
the risk of some potentially dangerous
side effects in the case of neomycin
those side effects are things like
deafness like ring in your ears cd c
diff um
infection etc not surprisingly a lot of
doctors are very hesitant to prescribe
it in fact you can't even buy it at a
regular pharmacy you actually have to
have it compounded because it's just
very infrequently prescribed because it
is potentially dangerous now the
evidence suggests that some of these
terrible side effects are actually seen
with long-term use and an iv use not so
much in these really short durations of
use like what you would be doing with
sibo but still understandably it freaks
a lot of physicians out and since a lot
of doctors don't actually know a whole
lot about sibo and in fact a lot of
physicians and healthcare professionals
don't even acknowledge that sibo is a
real thing um they're understandably
hesitant to prescribe anything that
comes with these significant risks so
i've now spoken to three different
doctors and nobody will prescribe me the
drugs and there's no point me doing
another round of rifaximin because i've
done it twice and we've seen from my
sibo results and repeating them that it
didn't work it just came back and in
fact it came back a little bit worse and
i actually spoke to a bunch of my rd
colleagues from different provinces in
canada and the states and it seems that
you know ontario seems to be a little
bit behind in our understanding of sibo
um and which is strange to me because
the tests are run out of you know
ontario and toronto's major hospital
mount sinai i even called cedar sinai
which is in la where um the doctor there
is kind of like the godfather of sibo
but they were willing to take me on as a
patient but they'd only see me in person
not virtually and honestly i can't just
fly to la to get a prescription so
this has been a humbling experience and
definitely evidence that you know
there's definitely some challenges and
gaps in our health care system it's an
amazing health care system and i'm so
grateful for it and i'm so grateful for
free health care here in canada but
you know it's not without its challenges
in getting timely effective care
sometimes so
anyways i'm gonna keep pressing on and
just hoping i can find a healthcare
professional who will help
i'm so frustrated i'm just so
mad and and nervous now i'm going to go
through this whole exercise of even
taking this biofilm disruptor which is
an expensive medication to begin with
and i'm not going to have anyone to
support me in this journey like you
would not believe how many people many
dietitians colleagues of mine that i've
spoken to who have had sibo or have sibo
or who deal with patients who have sibo
every day and they cannot find
practitioners and and doctors to support
their care
why does nobody believe this is real
like we have a diagnostic tool run out
of canada's top hospital and while the
specificity isn't perfect you know in
the hands of a skilled practitioner it's
a pretty great tool
it is just so archaic that you know
so many doctors are just dismissing this
as naturopathic woo we have research on
this we have research suggesting that
like 6 to 15
of asymptomatic healthy people are
affected by sibo and that it could be as
high as like 70 to 80 of people with ibs
you would think that with those kind of
numbers every research lab and
pharmaceutical company would be
clamoring to find a foolproof cure you
know
i'm normally so proud to be part of the
evidence-based wellness community but
it's times like these i fully understand
why people need to seek out alternative
practitioners or healthcare when there's
so much freaking red tape to even people
acknowledging when there's a problem
i feel
so let down by the system it should not
be making me more sick to try to get
better okay so update i was finally able
to find a doctor who's well-versed in
methanogenix sibo to help me you know
prescribe the right protocol so that i
can really just like put this to bed and
finish this off and do it right so
she was very helpful of course but she
also scared the
living out of me because she made it
very clear that she really could only
prescribe the neomycin once um and that
of course is to help reduce the risk of
any of the dangerous side effects and
antibiotic resistance so basically what
she told me was that if i didn't go kind
of all in on this and literally do
everything in my power to eradicate um
the bacteria this round that i may have
no other option but to do the elemental
diet and that is
literal torture and i'm not sure i'm
mentally prepared for that like it's
literally a diet of amino acids to help
starve off the bacteria for two weeks i
mean all of this is about weighing you
know the risks and benefits and i'm not
sure that the benefits outweigh the risk
to
my mental health especially somebody who
came from an eating disorder background
like there are a lot of people who i
would say the elemental diet is
contraindicated for and i'm just gonna
throw myself in there and say yeah
not for me because i want to do this
properly i reached out to two of my
colleagues who specialize in sibo to
really help review my protocol and offer
any other evidence-based tips or
suggestions when it comes to supplements
uh throughout this journey well i spoke
to diane rishikoff who's actually
written a book about this i'm gonna link
to that below and then anya rosen as
well two amazing practitioners so i'm
gonna link to their websites below so in
case you're struggling with sibo
yourself and you'd like some one-on-one
support they know their stuff but this
is really my again disclaimer that my
protocol is unique to me it's unique to
my numbers it's unique to my particular
type of sibo um so as always do not just
copy what i'm doing ever that can be
dangerous always speak to registered
dietitian like anya like diane for a
personalized protocol for yourself
so i just got off the phone with two
colleagues of mine back to back who are
of course so helpful and there seems to
be
some solid consensus here on what i need
to do in order to give myself the best
chance of success and i have to say that
you know i'm a professional and even i
feel so
overwhelmed with everything that like i
have to do and i have to buy and have to
get and
it's like you know it's i'm a little
stressed out over it so much so that i
was feeling quite queasy i had all the
digestive distress following the call
that none of me like lava which is
generally what happens when i feel
anxious but yeah once you get into the
world of functional nutrition
it's like you're unpeeling this this
never-ending onion there's just so much
to unpack and none of it is black and
white there isn't like a gold standard
here for treatment and a lot of it is
you know trial and error and it's
grounded in more clinical experience and
in science but not actually really good
quality research yet and that's honestly
just because the research hasn't caught
up yet um not in the pharmaceutical
world and definitely not in the world of
nutrition and lifestyle recommendations
and herbs and supplements or anything
like that i really think we're on the
cusp of knowing so much more about the
gut microbiome and sibo specifically and
like give it five years and doctors are
gonna be diagnosing sibo daily and we're
gonna have a lot more evidence to
support the use of specific protocols
right now for the most part this is
really just like a risk benefit analysis
every step of the way so the way i feel
about sibo and nutrition or supplements
is a lot like how i felt when i was
going through ivf and infertility like
the online infertility and ivf community
is huge and they're very vocal about oh
you know take this specific supplement
this helped me conceive or cut this food
out of your diet or don't have caffeine
or don't have alcohol or make sure
you're having a pineapple a day or
whatever and
like with sibo recommendations a lot of
these things aren't necessarily grounded
in research or really heavily
evidence-based a lot of the
recommendations might be based more on
like the role of a nutrient or a
supplement in isolation but how much of
those things or exactly how well they're
going to improve outcomes in real life
for the most part we might not know and
in a lot of cases i would argue or at
least i would bet that they probably
don't make a huge impact in isolation
but you know what does have a huge
impact on health outcomes
your mind especially when it comes to
gut health like your mental state has a
huge impact on your physical well-being
especially when it comes to the brain
gut access so this is a really big
connection when it comes to kind of gut
and digestive health i know when i was
going through ivf as evidence-based as i
was my doctor offered for me to be part
of basically an experiment um an
experimental procedure there was no
studies on it no research papers written
about it nothing had been presented at
conferences about it i was patient
number nine
and guess what in that case it worked
out for me it gave me my son when the
reality is i was told that probably
nothing else was going to work so when i
say something doesn't have evidence to
support it it doesn't necessarily mean
that it doesn't work or you shouldn't
try it but you do need to weigh out the
risks and benefits of these kinds of
things and ask yourself some really
important questions can i afford this
will this procedure or supplement make
me feel more stressed or make me feel
more in control even if it's just a
placebo are there physical risks to my
health by doing it are there emotional
or mental health risks will this impact
my relationship with food or my
relationship with others in a negative
way will i be upset if i try this and it
doesn't work or will i be upset if i
don't try this and it doesn't work these
are all questions that i need to ask
myself on the regular here is this how i
like to do business when it comes to my
health no i like to see
a list of all benefits and no downfalls
no cons and there are some things that
are definitely holding me back from
jumping all in mainly a fear of making
myself emotionally crazy and it being
all for nothing like i'm gonna have to
make myself a schedule right now with
all the different medications and
supplements and when i have to take them
and set alarms on my phone because some
things need to be taken twice a day
sometimes three times a day some of them
have to be taken before meals with meals
separated
it's gonna be overwhelming for me it's a
lot for me to think about having to
prioritize my schedule all of a sudden
when i'm so used to prioritizing oh
schedule and e-schedule and my husband's
schedule and mine just having to like
fit in somewhere plus i don't want to
have to cut foods out of my diet i don't
want to have to think about food that
much i don't want to obsess over food
i'm worried this could trigger some very
dark thoughts
i just really hope that it works
so stay tuned for my sibo eradication
protocol and my shocking results and
please leave me a comment if you have
any questions
[Music]